أنا وأنا صغير، ولا زلت إلى الآن
لا زلت أعاني من صعوبات في الكلام
لا زالت عندي تأتأة
وحتى إلى الآن، ما أدري لو لاحظت التأتأة
أثناء حديثي معك لا زالت موجودة
القصة تبدأ من يوم كان عمري تقريبًا ثمانية سنوات
في الصف ثاني ابتدائي أتذكر
دخل علينا الأستاذ
ووضع أمامي المصحف
وقال لي اقرأ
ولما بدأت اقرأ، بدأت اتأتئ
ويعطيني كف!
«أيش فيك أنت ما تفهم؟»
«اقرأ مرة ثانية»
أحاول مرة ثانية، واتأتئ. ويعطيني كف ثاني
«أنت غبي ما تعرف؟ اقرأ»
دموعي تسيل على وجهي، وأحاول اقرأ
برضه تأتأت، قال وقف
«أنت شكل ما منك فائدة»
أيقنت أنه أنا فعلًا ما مني فائدة
ومن الابتدائي إلى آخر مرحلة في.. ثالث ثانوي
ما كنت أتحدث مع أحد
كنت دائمًا أجلس في آخر الفصل
ساكت، طوال الوقت ساكت
إذا فتحت فمي وتكلمت بنضرب أو بينضحك علي
أو بظهر أمام الآخرين هذا الإنسان فيه عيب أو نقص
أيش لي في الكلام؟ خلّني ساكت أحسن لي
كانت بدايتي في الإذاعة المدرسية في الصف الثالث ثانوي
لما بدأت أتحدث، بدأت اتأتئ. والطلاب كلهم ضحكوا
واليوم اللي بعده وقفت
تكلمت
تأتأت، وضحكوا علي
واليوم اللي بعده ضحكوا علي، بس لاحظت أنه كل يوم
بعض الكلمات اللي كنت اتأتئ فيها اليوم اللي قبله
صرت ما اتأتئ فيها الآن
من وقتها صرت خلاص
أي فرصة اغتنمها أني أقف أمام الجمهور
كنت دائمًا أمثِّل الأدوار الكوميدية
ليه؟ حاط في بالي قلت دام أنهم بيضحكون
خليهم يضحكون معاي، ولا يضحكون علي
انتهت من المرحلة الثانوية وقدمت على برنامج أرامكو للابتعاث
وابتعثت إلى الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية، في عالم جديد
شعب جديد، أستطيع أني ابدأ بداية جديدة
كنت أداوم في النهار
وفي الليل كنت أروح إلى أندية «ستاند أب كوميدي»
وأوقف
أحيانًا أخبص، أحيانًا أقدم زين
لكن خلال الأربع سنين اللي في الجامعة
كانت هي اللي لاحظت فيها التأتأة عندي تقريبًا اختفت
وأعتقد لأنها لما رحت هناك، بدأت...
أو حاولت أني ابدأ شخصية جديدة
اللغة الإنقليزية
كانت بالنسبة لي إنسان ثاني
غير عن الإنسان اللي كان يحاول أنه يتجنّب الحديث أو الناس
لما انتهت أنا من الدراسة الجامعية ورجعت
طبعًا ألتحقت في شركة أرامكو
لمدة أربعة أو خمسة سنين ابتعّدت عن الحديث أمام الجمهور والإلقاء
وكنت خلال هذه الفترة أشتغل على مشروع
في النهاية طلبوا مني عرض تقديمي أو أني أقدمه إلى مجلس الإدارة
طبعًا في بالي قلت حاجة سهلة
أنا من أول كنت أقدم، صح وللا لا؟
سويت العرض حقي
ولما وقفت أتكلم، لاحظت أن التأتأة رجعت لي أقوى
كانت هذا أحد أسباب التحاقي بأندية الخطابة
أنا كنت أشتغل مدرب
فكان يجيني موظفين من كل الدوائر
وكعادة أي مدرب في البداية
لازم ابدأ اسألهم
في يوم من الأيام جاءني هذا الشخص
سألته أيش اسمك؟ قال اسمي محمد القحطاني
فعلّق
أنا خفت، أول مرة أشوف شخص يتأتئ بهذه الشدة
فقلت له: محمد ترى هذا نادي خطابة
يعني جمهور، منصة، مسرح
هل أنت متأكد؟ قال أيه بسجل، قدام
التحاقي في الأندية ما كان عشان أشترك في المسابقة
أو أفوز في اللقب
التحاقي بس عشان أتخلص من مشكلة التأتأة اللي عندي
وفعلًا أتذكر أول خطبة له
كانت شوية مربكة للغرفة، لأنه كلهم الآن شافوه وهو يتأتئ
بالرغم أننا انصدمنا شوي لأنه يتأتئ
إلّا أنه بسرعة غمرنا بالفكاهة
وخلّانا نضحك
عام 2010
جاءني رئيس النادي وقتها، قال
يا أبو حميد ما شاء الله عليك، أنت من الأعضاء اللي دائمًا...
أيش رأيك تشارك في مسابقة الخطابة؟
قلت أيش المسابقة هذه؟
قال هذه مسابقة تكون على مستوى النادي
إذا فزت، تسابق على مستوى المنطقة الشرقية
إذا فزت، تسابق على مستوى المملكة
وإذا فزت، تمثِّل المملكة في نهائيات العالم
احنا كلنا تسابقنا سنة، سنتين، ثلاثة سنوات
طقطقنا شوي، زين
جربنا، فزنا شوي، خسرنا كثير
لكن محمد كان يميّزه شيء
الوحيد في تاريخ النادي كله
اللي بقى يتسابق في كل سنة
كان دائمًا يخسر
يعني قلت لك، يفوز مرحلة أو مرحلتين ويطلع
وأنا من النوع اللي ما يتقبل الخسارة بكل رحب مثل ما قالوا
هذيك السنة، أنا أتذكر تمامًا أيش اللي صار
حط الخبر أنه طلع الثاني على المملكة في فيس بوك
وحط صورة الدرع
وقال.. أتذكر بالضبط أيش قال
قال «المركز الثاني، الحمدلله. وإن شاء الله السنة الجاية لنا رجعة»
ما يأست، ما حزنت. بالعكس
انبسطت
ثاني أفضل متحدث على مستوى المملكة
اللي فاز بالمركز الأول على مستوى المملكة في ذاك العام
الله يذكره بالخير، اسمه عبدالله الجوف من الرياض
قبل النهائيات بأسبوعين يجيني اتصال
وأجي أرد
كيف حالك أب حميد؟ قلت الحمدلله
قال معك عبدالله الجوف، حبيت اسألك عندك فيزا لأمريكا؟
قلت عندي، آمر
قال الوالد شوي تعبان، صعبة أروح وأخليه
بسحب اسمي، بما أنك صاحب المركز الثاني؛ تأخذ مكاني
أنا الثاني على المملكة، وبنافس المركز الأول من كل أنحاء العالم
بروح هناك بخسر وبرجع
وأسبوعين كاملة
كل أعضاء النادي حقي اللي في الظهران ومكة كلهم
الكل وقف معي
وأكتب الخطاب وأراجعها
وأوقف قدامهم وألقِّيها
أصحّح وأعدل هذه
لمدة أسبوعين، كل يوم
جاءت الرحلة ورحنا من هنا
مئة متسابق من أنحاء العالم
في البداية بيعملون القرعة
بيحطون كل عشرة أشخاص في مجموعة
المهم، وألقيت خطابي
قالوا اللي فاز من المجموعة الثالثة محمد القحطاني
الحين وصلت النهائي
وأفضل عشرة متحدثين على مستوى العالم
ويطلع الأول ويبدأ يتكلم
وأنا في الغرفة جالس أناظر
كان مبدع
الحركات، الصوت استخدام المسرح. آسَّر الجميع
وأنا أناظر فيه قلت يمكن أخذ الثاني
ويطلع اللي بعده، أحسن من الأول
يمكن أخذ الثالث
كل واحد هذاك اليوم طلع أحسن من اللي قبله
وصلت إلى مرحلة قلت ما بفوز
أنسى، ما بتفوز
جاء دوري
ركبوا عليّ «المايكروفون»
ألقيت خطابي ونزلت وخلصت، وصفقوا الجميع
ولا زال عندي إيقان
يا محمد ما بتفوز
لكن على الأقل أعطيت اللي عندك وأكثر
يعني طفل ما كان يتكلم
طفل كان أكبر خوفه يفتح فمه أمام شخص
ولو تقول لأي شخص
أنه يوم من الأيام محمد القحطاني بيوقف هنا
بيقول مستحيل
الكلمة هذه اللي فازت في بطولة العالم
هي ليست كلمة محمد القحطاني فقط
إنما كلمة كل أعضاء التوسماسترز اللي هنا في أرامكو
وحتى اللي برا أرامكو داخل المملكة
أنا مجرد الصوت اللي وقّف وقالها
انتهت المسابقة
وفي لحظة كتابة هذه الكلمات
يستعد محمد القحطاني للعودة إلى الوطن
وفي هدوء غرفة الفندق
يجد نفسه وحيدًا مع ذكريات الطفولة
حين عانى من مشاكل في النطق
فيسخر منه جميع الطلاب
أنه محمد القحطاني، بطل العالم في الخطابة 2015
لا زلت تخاف من المسرح؟
جدًا، دائمًا. هذا الخوف أصلًا مستحيل يروح
لكن توصل إلى مرحلة تعرف كيف تستخدمه
هل تختار يكون عائق أمامك أو دافع لن أترك الأمر
إذا أنت مستعد أنك تحاول
وتفشل مرة ومرتين وعشرة وعشرين
وتتعلم من كل مرة ما استطعت أنك توصل فيها
أيش الشيء اللي اخطأت فيه؟
تعيد المحاولة وتتجنّب هذه الأخطاء
مهما كان
المستحيل غير موجود